[Music]
these are the classic images of the
drugs trade police raids dirty needles
knife crime and violence but what you
hear less about is the market sustaining
this so let me tell you a see Britain's
most popular class a drug is everywhere
if you don't do it someone you know does
it's used if throughout society there is
no actual profile of a cocaine user in
the UK it's just socially acceptable
these days it is a Class A drug and I
found out that the hard way this is the
open secret and that's what it is it's
an open secret but for the first time
we're able to show you the immense
quantities we consume we don't talk
about cocaine because everyone's taking
it it's sort of recreational yeah that's
the word that's its recreation I isn't
it recreational because wrong with it it
destroys lives let's start here in
Suffolk this stream feeding the Stour
River hides a clue to our drug
consumption because these watery veins
of the countryside are flown
yes
Shrimant that clean dirt on the riverbed
have been harvested by scientists at
King's College London and every sample
tested was positive for cocaine the same
with rag worms and snails from other
rivers in the English countryside in
every single sample we found cocaine
which really was a surprise for us it's
I'd expect something like that perhaps
in London so what about London Leon's
team has conducted a new study on the
capital's sewage water and shared the
results with Sky News a spike on this
graph would be evidence of a compound
produced by cocaine as it passes through
the body and is then flushed down the
loo okay so here's our cocaine peak
coming out
so what we're monitoring here is
actually a metabolite of cocaine this is
called benzylic Kony yeah and this peak
here tells me that the cocaine that I'm
detecting in the sewage is actually been
through a body so this shows me that
Reilly's taking the cocaine it confirms
that London consumes any more cocaine
than any other European city tested and
we have a high weekday use we see a
steadily high value across the week and
then it rises only by about 30% of the
weekends so really cocaine is an
everyday drug in London now for the
first time scientists have used the bio
marker to work out the actual quantities
of cocaine used in London and compared
it to 75 other European cities so we've
come to rights flour mill in North
London to illustrate the cocaine
consumption of our capital city in the
other seventy-five European cities
tested the average daily consumption of
cocaine is 0.76 kilograms but let's keep
pouring to get to the top four cities
Berlin consumes much more than average
at four point six two kilograms a day
let's add to that the consumption of
Amsterdam which is almost exactly the
same another four point six two
kilograms
add to this Barcelona's usage Europe's
second biggest consumer doubles the pile
they get through twelve point seven four
kilograms a day but London has a market
the size of those three cities combined
and so it's pile comes to twenty three
kilograms not just because of its large
population but also the high usage per
capita so this is what twenty three
kilos of pure cocaine looks like but you
have to imagine that the suppliers add
in various cutting agents and substances
in order to increase their profits so
the actual pile would be much much
bigger than that and this is what is
consumed in London on average every
single day with a single dose at 40
milligrams this pile amounts to more
than half a million doses a day although
some consume more than one dose in a
single line of cocaine the street value
is around two and three-quarter million
pounds a day now if you want to see what
that looks like on an annual scale here
it is in bags of flour London uses 8
tonnes of pure cocaine in the course of
a year
[Music]
the sewage tests were done in one other
British City and here cocaine use has
increased fourfold in his many years and
Bristol has rocketed past London to the
top of the European chart for
consumption per capita on a night out we
met hairdressers bar staff a teacher and
medical world who said they used cocaine
we've decided not to show faces of those
who admitted music I do like it is very
regular you do get like a lot of people
offering on the streets and stuff you
can notice when someone's not just on
alcohol you know people don't leave
sometimes tools are swinging yeah yeah
it's common knowledge you know when when
you go out in town you're gonna meet a
few people that are on the 80s image of
cocaine was the posh party drug yuppie
bankers snorting lines for lunch but the
middle-class recreational user is still
criticized for the habit as mayor the
Met Commissioner and most recently by
the Prime Minister the evil county lines
drugs guns that could date on young kids
and send them to die in the streets to
feed the cocaine habits of the
bourgeoisie but county lines dealers
predominantly trade in crack cocaine and
heroin and experts say that even powder
cocaine does now transcend profession
and class people think always it's it's
a middle-class middle-aged dinner party
drug but our experience is certain from
what we see online it's everywhere it's
your 18 year old it's your 20 year old
it it's people in our states and people
you know you know gated communities it's
the whole lot so why has it become more
prolific one reason is the wholesale
price has come down more international
crime networks have entered the market
and it's become more competitive
shipments from Colombia are ever more
ambitious with large concealments in
containers of legitimate goods
for cocaine is commonly fruit but not
exclusively so pineapples and bananas
one two of the most common we can see
more of those than any other country in
Europe using pineapples as a playful
earth exercise would you'd expect to see
them coming to the UK and then using the
pineapple itself as an additional visual
concealment the concealment is very well
crafted these pineapples intercepted in
Spain last year certainly didn't look
tampered with so the idea with that is
that on an initial inspection norm will
see the cocaine and of course if you're
really suspicious you look at people and
just there's the outer monocle
once in the UK there are numerous supply
routes not just County lines but the
dark web is a growing marketplace we
persuaded an online dealer to explain
this side of the industry which relies
on eBay style trader ratings
there's a nice disconnect there so you
have to feel socially responsible for
meeting a drug dealer in the street or
worried about him maybe giving you some
dodgy stuff you got a form of recourse
there with the feedback system which is
quite nice you're able to make a decent
markup basically oh yeah can you say
roughly what percentage in some
occasions I've had some substances which
don't really deal with anymore but at
some point in time I was able to markup
hundreds of percent and in some cases
nearly a thousand percent so I'd be able
to go down to the post box and put two
or three letters in the post box and
that'll be a week's work after about a
hundred grand you don't really want to
make money any more you know two grand a
week is the limit you know so as soon as
you make two grand a week
yeah that's enough to go on holiday with
greater availability comes greater
quality prices remain reasonably stable
but however purity over the last few
years has begin to increase and it's a
high high-end purity now it would
suggest that we've got a more developed
and discerning marketplace I think it I
think it suggests that people are you
know they want the higher purity cocaine
they don't want if we went back ten
years purity on street level was down to
three to five percent purity and if
purity is now forty percent
effectively cocaine's retail price is
cheaper and the other side of the coin
is it's more addictive cocaine anonymous
now holds over 600 meetings a week in
the UK we've been given rare access to
one in Bristol where addicts come from
all walks of life recent research shows
that women are less likely to seek help
for their addiction and I'm curious as
to why I had this life where I was kind
of like on show and working and married
and my children and that I had this
other life that was secret and I was
just terrified of people find it out
people thinking I was a terrible mother
because I thought I was a terrible
mother I thought I was telling mother I
would sit on a night by the babies costs
sobbing knocking at the babies thinking
why can't I stop why do I keep doing
this and I was just terrified that
someone to come and take them
but while addiction is a taboo addicts
say the recreational acceptability of
the drug has fuelled their problem it
starts out with a lot of fun and I was
partying a lot weather and it just
seemed like a really socially acceptable
drug to be using because everybody was
doing it and it's that kind of
middle-class drug and then and then
suddenly I was the one chasing the party
all the time
well I fall into the Hollywood Life
really you know the cocaine champagne
type of thing that came across in you
know in wood films when I was working in
his hairdressers like all the other
stylists we'd all get together they
would rack up a line like you know and
it was like out the back room out the
back in the kitchen of the of the
hairdresser's and this was like a
respectable white middle-class
hairdressers and I wanted to be part of
it author and columnist briney Gordon
has written about her addiction there's
a lot of kind of snobbery actually
celebrities taking middle-class
journalists like me take it
middle-class politicians take it and and
therefore it's okay to take it's either
okay to take it or it's not it can't be
as problematic but it is a problem the
tests in Bristol suggests that markets
outside of London
growing the price is falling making
cocaine more accessible and the purity
is making it more addictive yet still
we're not properly talking about our
secret habit the UK will try almost any
drug presented to it and very often
sadly not only do we try and we've
become sustained usable it's a
progressive disease but I suffer with
can't ever start again because if I
start again little bit taught me to look
beyond the drug taking to the reasons
for the drug taking you know nothing
good comes of cocaine use
[Music]